A knitter asked, can I use this
card for any stitch pattern?
What do you think?
Well, let's go back to the
function of a punch card.
If you have an electronic machine,
the ideas here are the same.
The black holes tell the machine
which needles to select.
What happens to the stitches on those
needles depends on your carriage setting.
I happen to know that this stitch pattern
was designed for a G-carriage, also
called an automatic knitting carriage.
These were made for the Brother,
Knit King, standard gauge machines.
The knitting will look like this.
Can you see both knit and purl stitches?
But what if we tried to knit
this as a tuck stitch?
We can't knit tuck needles side by side.
Remember how Tuck stitch is formed.
The yarn loops over the needles
and needles right next to each other will
get great big loops and just make a mess.
So in viewing this card,
we can immediately see that there are
holes side by side, not good for tuck.
The same thing goes for slip.
Slipping lots of needles side by side
will create really long floats. Again,
remember how slip stitches formed.
The working yarn is carried under
the needles, forming floats.
Short floats can be decorative.
But this row is 24 stitches wide
and we'd have a 24 stitch float.
Think of free pass where
there's no needles knitting.
Could this stitch pattern
be used for Fair Isle?
Well, I suppose, but every other row would
be yellow in this case and the blue would
be carried across. Again,
really long floats and it's not
particularly attractive anyways.
So the bottom line, can you use this
card for other stitch patterns?
No.
You can tell by examining the position
of the holes on the stitch pattern.